c'est corti bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
depuis le début du déconfinement on
parle d'une possible deuxième vague un
rebond de l'épidémie ce risque est il
réel aujourd'hui ça fait partie des
hypothèses épidémiologique à savoir que
qu'il puisse y avoir un rebond
ceci dit on n'est pas suffisamment
informée aujourd'hui sur le caractère
saisonnier ou pas de l'épidémie on s'est
ainsi répétée cela s'atténue et ou pas
ce qui est clair c'est que le
confinement a fait son effet et et
qu'aujourd'hui et le virus reste actif
dans beaucoup de régions et donc il faut
être prudent parce que parce que à tout
moment ça peut refluant b dans
différence que ce qu'on appelle des
clusters donc rester vigilant évidemment
le nombre de cas a baissé mais moi dans
ma pratique au quotidien je vous reçois
encore beaucoup de patients issus de
dépistage de six thématiques notamment
dans les centres d'hébergement ça veut
dire que le virus est toujours là mais
qu'il faut être prudent
à paris on a pu voir des scènes la
semaine dernière avec des rassemblements
au bord notamment du canal saint martin
ce week-end il a fait extrêmement beau
il y avait de nombreux passants des
passants qui n'observent pas souvent la
distanciation sociale est ce que ces
comportements vous choque
je parle de plus des effets du thé
confinement que d'un certain relâchement
on a quand même des français qui ont
intégré la menace qu'ils sont assez
quasiment deux mois enfermés qu'ils ont
inspecté ses mesures sanitaires
liberticide
aujourd'hui il est normal que les gens
retournent au travail que des enfants
puissent aller à l'école et dans ces
conditions c'est plutôt des déchets du
déconfinement qu'il faut suivre
je ne parlerai pas forcément de
relâchement ce qui est clair c'est que
des français notamment à paris mais ont
besoin de sortir et qui a pas d' espace
parler du canal saint-martin mais tout
autour les parcs éoliens pas beaucoup
sont fermées donc il est normal que dans
ces conditions la personne devant les
difficultés à respecter des
distanciation tels que les mesures
barrières proposait donc moi je m'étonne
d'ailleurs que
qu'à paris on n'est pas vraiment vers
les parcs parce que ça permettrait
justement de limiter cette proximité de
fait parce qu'il n'ya pas de panne pas
d'autres possibilités
alors les parcs et jardins sont toujours
fermés comme vous venez de le mentionner
à paris mais par contre les transports
en commun sont accessibles est-ce que
voilà les transports en commun ne sont
pas un risque présente pas un risque
plus élevé
oui on voit bien que les risques en lien
avec le déconfinement c'est
essentiellement le fait de retourner au
travail dans des espaces où on va être
confronté à d'autres personnes dans le
fait de prendre les moyens de transport
et on voit bien que ils sont limités et
que donc il est difficile de respecter
les mesures barrières même si la plupart
des français on porte des masques
aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut quand même
savoir c'est que on est il ya beaucoup
de geri évidemment de la maladie que on
est plus préparé qu'avant de confit nous
rendre en matière de capacité de suivre
les quatre contacts direction on
diagnostique une personne on va avoir la
possibilité de les autres de retracer
les contacter et donc d'essayer de
circonscrire sur le terrain les peelings
donc on est mieux préparée il ya plus
comme de masse puisque de gels
hydroalcooliques se faire en sorte
qu'ils soient accessibles de manière
inconditionnelle et dans ces conditions
aussi suivre les courbes d'épidémiologie
parce que ce que l'on sait c'est que on
aura vraiment les effets et les
résultats et des confinement est
peut-être un rebond d'ici la fin de la
semaine
donc il faudra vraiment surveiller d'ici
la fin de la semaine
début de semaine prochaine on pourra
vraiment con connaître les effets de ce
déconfinement et si jamais ça ça
repartait un petit peu à la hausse
quelle mesure devra devra comprendre
aujourd'hui
évidemment comme je le disais on on
n'est pas certain dévolu sur d'épidémie
mais ce qu'on sait c'est que d'ici début
de semaine prochaine fin cette semaine
on pourra envisager et voir s'il y a des
redémarrages des rebonds aujourd'hui on
est mieux équipé pour pouvoir
circonscrire sur le terrain les pays je
ne pense pas que mais je ne suis pas un
politique donc c'est pas moi décider
mais je pense pas qu'aujourd'hui on soit
obligé à nouveau de confier à l'échelle
nationale
capacité selon les endroits où il y aura
des femmes cluster il y aura des
relances ont pas la capacité de
circonscrire l'épidémie en local et s'il
faut reconfigurer ce qui est une
hypothèse où que ce soit par région ou
de manière nationale
ça reste quelque chose qui est qui devra
être envisagée si l'épidémie il repart
encore une fois si ces deux sont des
foyers très localisés il pourra y avoir
du confinement localiser si c'est plus
globale évidemment ce sera des mesures
nationales mais on est prêt aujourd'hui
pour anticiper des reprises dans
différentes régions de manière localisée
jean françois corty merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes médecin généraliste et ex
directeur des opérations internationales
de médecins du monde